división en el seno de la unión europea
mientras que buenos países argumentan
que la extensión temporal de las
patentes de la vacuna contra el joven 19
no sería una solución inmediata a la
crisis sanitaria otros como francia que
apoyo a la iniciativa de eeuu de liberar
la propiedad intelectual de los fármacos
se enfocan en una prioridad más urgente
el aumento de la producción pero hago un
claro llamado a eeuu para que ponga fin
a la prohibición de exportaciones a las
vacunas pero también a los ingredientes
que impiden su producción hoy prueban
nos dice no podemos producir una vacuna
en europa porque algunos ingredientes
están bloqueados en eeuu lo que la clave
para producir vacunas más rápidamente
para todos los países pobres e
intermedios es producir más levanten las
prohibiciones a las exportaciones
levanten las los países anglosajones son
señalados de quedarse prácticamente con
el 100 por ciento de las vacunas que
fabrican mientras que la unión europea
subraya que exporta el 50 por ciento de
su producción macro sostiene que
levantar las patentes no sería útil si
muchos países no cuentan con el
conocimiento o la
para una producción idónea sin embargo
la medida fue apoyada por el papá
francisco y una variante de este virus
es el nacionalismo encerrado que impide
por ejemplo un internacionalismo de las
vacunas otra variante es cuando creemos
y fomentamos una economía enferma que
permite que unos pocos muy ricos unos
pocos muy ricos posean más que todo el
resto de la humanidad el debate toma
fuerza en medio de una fuerte
desigualdad en la repartición de las
vacunas a nivel mundial en el continente
americano
eeuu ha aplicado más de 240 millones de
dosis mientras que países como honduras
no llega a las 100.000 inoculaciones